and it feels like we should start of
course with the disaster that struck in
Granville tower 58 people missing
presumed dead huge questions remain
unanswered about everything from the
cladding to sprinklers in the building
how these people been failed by the
government well it is a terrible tragedy
and every time you watch the news you
want to weep all those people have
suffered the people of families of those
who've lost their lives I think what it
shows is that the Kinsella party have to
be the party of social reform we have to
be the part of redistribution and I'll
explain what that means we have to be
the party of social justice we have to
be the party for workers and we need to
show people that actually our main
mission is to help those who are
disadvantaged who the who live on low
incomes do you think that the response
to the tragedy in the last the day is
following it has perhaps shown that many
people don't see the concept at party in
the way that you described that people
are taken to the streets to protest
because they believe that the
Conservative Party is more bothered
about the rich and not the poor I think
whenever there's a tragedy like this the
response is always difficult and you
always need to find out what has
occurred but not just with the Grenfell
tragedy there is an underlying I believe
an underlying feeling amongst many
people across the country that the
Conservatives it's not so much the party
of the rich but the causes are not on
the side of those of low incomes and the
Prime Minister when she arrived in
Downing Street made a powerful speech
that reached out to millions and I think
it was one of the reasons why at the
beginning her popularity was high which
said that she wanted a Britain that work
for everyone and said that she wanted to
reach out to those who are disadvantaged
it was one of the reasons why I
supported and we've got to get back to
that do you think you've gone away from
it then since that speech well I think
there are a host of things that come up
in government governments like a big
ship sails to a destination you have
storms every day sometimes you have to
veer I'd be a left we've all had these
terrible terrorism outrages as well but
I think this has to be our central
mission if the Conservative Party is to
survive and to ever get a healthy
majority and I don't just mean a working
majority or a coalition
we have to show all the people that we
are on all of the people sighs whatever
background that they come from that's
why I say talk about social justice and
redistributions or what I mean by
redistribution not necessarily the labor
term but we say that we raise extra
money by cutting taxes for the well-off
we say that we raise extra monies by
cutting business taxes corporation tax
actually that's true the figures show
that I think what we need to do is
redistribute those extra monies raised
from cutting taxes for the well-off or
cutting taxes or business and focus that
money in a special redistribution fund
to help our poorest communities
particularly the kind of people who live
in Grenfell Tower or lived in grenfell
Tower and elsewhere across our country
earlier on this week and you had some
pretty harsh words I guess for the
future of the Conservative Party we can
just have a look at what you did say you
said that the Conservative Party is on
death row I mean that is a pretty
forlorn statement about where you
believe your party is heading and things
really that bad well I think that of
course we increased our vote share but
if you increase vote share in very safe
areas but actually lose seats or have
hyper marginal seats up and down the
country and do so badly in London I
think we need to ask searching questions
I think this is the time to it but to be
fair the Prime Minister has done that
she came to meet the Conservative MPs
last week I think she recognises the
challenges that we face as a party but I
think it is those but our duty I think
we need a fundamental a rebranding I
think we need to look fundamentally at
our narrative and I also think we need
to look fundamentally at our message and
our policies it it's true they really
the person who is going to be capable of
doing this because she just called the
selection lost seats is she really the
person broken I backed the Prime
Minister as I said when I was literally
inspired I think millions of people were
inspired when she first stood on the
steps of a still inspired by her I think
that the Prime Minister we have to have
the Prime Minister doing the job I think
she recognizes the problem she said
she's going to get us out of the mess
that occurred in the concerted party and
I believe her okay
there are reports in the papers today
that some MPs are preparing to sign
letters of no confidence in the Prime
Minister that they're giving her ten
days in which to turn things around
what are you honestly picking up on the
back benches what's the move I'm not one
of those people I my view is very simple
I don't think and we could have
Alexander the Great we've got a
Archangel Gabriel as lead of the
Conservative Party but unless we
fundamentally change and work out what
we stand for show people that we are on
the side of the most disadvantaged show
people that we are the real Workers
Party in terms of wages in terms of jobs
and skills in terms of welfare in terms
of Rights in terms of worker services
like energy bills then we won't achieve
what we want to do whoever is the leader
that's what your view is are you picking
up from some of your colleagues so that
they have perhaps rather less patience
they're always murmurings here and there
at any time but I think most of the
party wants to resume to continue I
think the country obviously is in a
difficult way at the present time in
terms of security in terms of the
tragedy that we've just witnessed over
the past few days and I think it would
be one to change the leader how long did
you give her as I say I think you'd be
wrong to change the leader I think that
what the country needs is there I say to
use the phrases some form of stability
because I think the country is the
country deserves it the country needs it
strong and stable leadership we thought
you'd be here saying that again rubber
half and thank you very much for coming
on the show and giving us your thoughts